those legit those Legit to Quit I I
that's the greatest part about this
podcast that has ever happened dude
especially if like you're in a group of
friends and you have more dude spread it
around be the one that like goes broke
spend it on your boys yep that's right
for whatever not to that extent but
that's what MC Hammer yeah that is what
he did he was like people like go hammer
go hammer go and he went and now he's
[ __ ] broke dude now he's gotta go get
a loan yeah he would perform it like you
know a high school graduation if you
paid him wow you know 2500 go hammer go
hammer go go go go go and they meant to
Wells Fargo to ask for a loan that's
what they mean all right cool sweat come
on all over my cheeks
then harder than ever did before when
and then we go Gotta make time with it
and they go and then when they were
there
instead of saying the RS like he was
Mexican the amount of sounds you made
yeah that go along with the amount of
words you saw that's very strange you
said made so many sounds so few words
here we go and now see now it's my turn
to talk right so you talked for a while
I let you talk now it's my turn to talk
just keep doing it right so now the way
we're gonna do it is I'm gonna talk
right just a little bit and then you
talk again okay go ahead okay I forgot
what I was gonna say go ahead he is
before that's what he said
yeah
[Music]
those legit wow made it so bad
those legit
yeah that's legit okay it was legit
those Legit to Quit hey hey those legit
wow no it would be like it would be
those Legit to Quit I I yeah
the slight difference it was legit those
legit that's the only word they would
change yeah those two I don't know oh I
know that I'm just saying what if the
song really was that it's in uh
[Laughter]
what is what is here he's looking it up
what's legit in Spanish oh wow it's
legit
it's right there dude
those legit my quit hey hey
Timo yeah
and then quit we do not quit I don't
know probably like
Thursday
doesn't have the same ring to it
doesn't have the simmering so bad
and I want you to stop
like so I'm ready to stop so bad that's
the greatest part about this podcast
that has ever happened dude and what's
interesting is if that's true how about
I want you to stop has to be the [ __ ]
absolute title of this don't be don't
burn bridges yeah yeah don't I mean
there's also there's also there's also a
way to
make sure to oh my god dude
oh my God look at that is
yeah yeah
um
not the same ring
[Music]
good
[Music]